Katie Herzog was a writer at the
stranger she's no longer there because
she was furloughed and she she offered
herself to be furloughed and now she's
independent she has a podcast called
blocked and reported and you should go
and join her patreon she's she's
incredibly bright she's a breath of
fresh air all the things you would say
about somebody who's cancelled all the
time ah that's what you say when
someone's cancelled you go there a pro
wouldn't breath of fresh air
they are but she's great I was in Palm
Springs that we tried to do this
interview but we could the Wi-Fi wasn't
working now it is much better we wanted
to have Raz Simeone the leader of the
Seattle autonomous home because they had
reached out to us you know they had
contacted me on Instagram Raz had
retweeted me maybe they had in the
interim found some of my earlier work or
maybe they had just gotten cold feet or
maybe Raz is reading emails from the CIA
about what he should do next I don't
know but I they they are welcome to come
I hope we have rise in the future but
Katie Herzog is here with us now what is
your read on the Seattle autonomous zone
are you going to go and explore it well
first of all you're getting the name
wrong you are a dead naming the Seattle
homicide it's actually the Capitol Hill
autonomous zone or Chas which is
probably the funniest part of all this
it sounds like a like a tennis coach I
find this whole thing extremely funny so
what people from outside Seattle might
not know is that the capital the area
where where this is happening where they
have declared an autonomous state
outside the jurisdiction of the United
States is in a really highly gentrified
neighborhood and my my former office is
actually in Chas so if I were still
working at this stranger I would be
entering you know entering the zone
every day which would be sort of ironic
because right now apparently during the
the protest someone someone graffiti'd
[ __ ] Herzog on the door of the stranger
so it might be a little bit awkward for
me to try to get to work through Chad's
at this point luckily that doesn't
happen so this area is super highly
gentrified it's the historic gay name
in Seattle and it still has like rainbow
crosswalks and lots of gay people and
said like that but it's also really
expensive it's mostly like you know like
chain ramen shops and 3000 $4000 studio
apartments a lot of amazon workers live
there so I'm I keep imagining what the
like well-heeled upper-middle class
Amazon workers think about their new
overlords and there's also so they've
taken over this Park and the park is
surrounded by multi-million dollar
condos and townhouses and so I just I'm
really curious about what the residents
of chad's think about about what is
happening to their neighborhood I'm sure
some are totally supportive and I'm sure
some are just absolutely terrified why
is the Pacific Northwest historically
been a bastion of of a lot of activism
and a lot of anarchists are out there
what is going on over there is it the
rain is it the weather are you wanna
some type of is it an energy vortex what
is happening with Portland and Seattle
and these places that make them such a
hotbed of this type of activity that's a
great question I don't know the history
of this how long this has been going on
I mean you know like 20 years ago were
the WTO rights in Seattle which were the
world the World Trade Organization had a
meeting there and the city just erupted
into total chaos much like we're seeing
now although a lot of it seems to have
calmed down in Portland of course has
its own fair share of activism the
cities are different and some in some
important ways and what's happening in
Portland and to a lesser extent in
Seattle is that so both of these these
are very blue cities that are surrounded
by can by more conservative suburbs and
rural areas and so in Portland what you
will have is like proud boys or Patriot
prayer or something these conservative
groups come in from the suburbs or the
rural areas and just sort of stage their
marches there and you know it's a lot of
American flags and pro-trump stuff and
then an Tifa and other like affiliated
are anarchists and just people who like
to fight in the streets will just come
in and respond to them and there's this
clash and it feels very much like you
know like LARPing like cosplay
sort of revolution cosplay where nothing
actually changes nobody's mind is chains
just some like [ __ ] gets destroyed and
then everybody you know the proud boys
go back to their go back to their
suburbs and the ante if it goes back to
their you know they're the coops that
they live in or their parents basement
or whatever yeah so it is interesting
both areas do tend to be hot beds for
this sort of political activism I mean
also both areas are sort of the cities
at least are politically very homogenous
so you have basically no presence of a
Republican Party and I think when you
have an ideologically homogeneous area
what happens is extremism you know if
you don't have anyone to sort of check
your ideas I just sort of naturally flow
to the edges of acceptable thought so I
think that's also probably a probably a
part of it where you know we hear a lot
about empty fun you know you see them
and you see the things they do and
they're absurd and then we see like you
know they're directing traffic and
they're not letting people go back you
know who like is aunt Eva
is there any organization is it just a
ragtag group of I mean what is it is it
in your estimation a terrorist network
like what is it and does it deserve that
type of designation I mean I don't know
what is it I don't I do not think in
chief as a terrorist organization I
don't even think aunt Eva is a big
threat to cities like Portland OR
Seattle that do have a larger presence
of an tisha antifa
it's just a group I mean anybody can
join in chief or black bloc or whatever
you just put on the put you put on the
outfit and you go hold up a protest sign
or cover your face with a with a
balaclava although these days
everybody's face is covered so a little
bit harder to pick auntie fat out of a
crowd it's not there's no hierarchy it's
you know it's anarchist in nature and
antifa sort of appears at moments and
then disappears as soon as they're as
soon as the fight is over it's not this
is not they don't have much political
but they don't have any political power
they're not a democratic group they're I
guess they're far-left but they don't
have political ideals in the way that we
think of sort of like get people elected
go through
legislative process I think their aims
are much more about dismantling the
state dismantling capitalism and I'm
sure there's lots of you know people who
are committed to the cause and there's
also lots of people who just like to you
know like to play pretend like to sort
of get all pissed off and go and break
some windows we were gonna do a sketch
called fat and Tifa
where me and my co straight comp we're
gonna dress up in all black and it was
guys that we're going to a March but
kept getting sidetracked by different
fast-food places and then at the end we
just attacked like a trump supporter
like a 14 year old and they beat the
[ __ ] out of us and we never filmed it
but it was an idea that we had
he's part when you look at these
protests and there's such valid anger
right I mean there's such righteous
justified anger Dave Chappelle did an
amazing job it like articulating it is
the major disconnect with a lot of these
protests what how how any of them lead
to political change like how does a
group of angry angry people who are very
justified in their anger how do they
affect the political process many people
believe that that can no longer happen
that we're living in a time where
elections you know don't matter at all
even local ones and that they're this
this chaotic energy will just be a means
and an end where these systems will all
somehow magically be remade I don't know
but is that one of the issues that
you're looking at this and going you
have this anger it makes a lot of sense
it's very justified but then a lot of it
seems to be like directed it like ending
isms and racism and capitalism and it
seems like well wait a minute why don't
we focus on one thing at a time which is
like ending police brutality and then
people say well that's a function of
your privilege you're talked about it's
just a function of my logical brain
going through how are you going to end
an ism during a pandemic and an economic
meltdown why don't why Kay so how do you
what do you see as the biggest issue
with these Pro
it's really enacting any type of real
reform or change well I think the
problem is that the loudest activists
are oftentimes out of touch with the
American people and so even if people
who support the protests who recognize
that police brutality is a problem that
corruption and police forces is a
problem that racism is a problem and the
two things can be disconnected you know
police brutality white people Asian
people Hispanics everybody is affected
by police brutality specific actually
Native Americans are the group most
affected by it and so if you divorce it
from sort of the cause of black lives
matter I personally think you would have
more legislative success because you can
build a core a bigger coalition if you
say police brutality and bad policing
affects every community in this country
every race in this country and it's not
going to alienate white people
particularly conservative white people I
think as much as the current sort of
protests have the potential to do and so
you have that problem and then you have
the problem of sort of the sloganeering
right so what you see in the streets and
what you see on the news if you turn on
the news is people chanting things like
abolish the police defund the police
this year these are not popular
positions and among the American
populace you know the protesters as
righteous as they feel and I do think
they have you know just reasons to be
angry and to feel righteous themselves
but these these radical policy positions
like abolishing the police are not
popular even among black communities
that suffer from the highest rates of
violence what they actually when you
pull when you look at polls of black
communities typically what they say is
we don't want to abolish the police we
want functional police we want the
police to to help us when we call them
to not ignore us and not to brutalize us
not to defund them and not to and
there's some irony here when you talk
about defunding the police well if you
defund the police that means there will
be fewer police men police people the
police forces which means that response
times when somebody calls sign on one
are gonna go up and according to the
Seattle Police Department this is this
is already happening right now then they
also have beautiful of [ __ ] so we
have to take everything
they say I think with a some skepticism
the police chief for instance this week
said that in Chad's businesses were
being [ __ ] you know shaking down for
money and basically that the residents
of Chad's were exhorting the local you
know they're their new tenants and it
turns out that this doesn't appear to be
true so I think we should be skeptical
that said once you talk to people if you
talk to protesters and you say like you
know were the leaders of these protests
I guess in some cases self-appointed
leaders and you know you might say like
well what do you mean by abolish to the
police and they say like oh we don't
really mean abolish the police we mean
like break the police force down and
rebuild it up is something different or
defund the police and use the money for
community policing but when you rely on
slogans
it's like build the wall you know or
something like that it's just sort of an
empty slogan and I think this has the
capacity to really turn people off I
mean that said I think they're seeing
some successes you know San Francisco
today the mayor of San Francisco and
announced some some police reform some
reforms to the police department that
could actually have an impact on police
brutality Minneapolis it looks like they
are going to sort of defund the police
and try to rebuild rebuild it into a
community policing organization or
something like that who knows if that
will be any different did you see that
Andrew yang tweet where he goes why
don't we just call them the Guardians
thing is like you can change the name
and if you still have the same populates
it's not gonna actually change anything
so I think a lot it a lot of this look
and hearing is empty or it's out of
touch with with how most Americans feel
but we are seeing I think some successes
from this group and we'll see we'll see
how long it goes you know I think
there's potential for leaders to emerge
that maybe could have a future in
politics although I'm not sure that
anybody anybody that I'm aware of has
particularly emerged on the national
stage at this point
Brianna Taylor's law just got passed
where they're getting rid of no-knock
warrants which are you know they're
right you know that that's a step in the
right direction but there there seems to
be this wing of people that aren't happy
with the word reform and they don't like
incremental change of any
kind and they don't like even me saying
things like that's a step in the right
direction they believe that the only way
to fix this system is to tear it all
down now to people like myself and
others that are marginally intelligent
we realize that that's not possible like
you're not going to happen and if you
defund the police rich communities are
going to hire private police forces that
probably have less accountability than
the public police forces right now that
you now you and this you got a lot of
issues as a writer in terms of people
getting angry at you people have called
you a turf which means you're a trans
exclusionary radical feminist or
something right is not what that means
that's the acronym I am NOT a turf or a
radical feminist or really even a
feminist at this point right but so I
guess I'm just radical feminist you I
think you wrote an article on Jordan
Peterson that that angered people what
was the beginning of Katie Herzog being
on the outs at the stranger which is we
would we would say is a very left-wing
publication out of Seattle and you you
became like persona non grata there how
did that happen it actually happened
before I was hired so I was a freelancer
writing in Seattle and and I one of the
first pieces that I wrote for the
stranger was called the D transitioners
and it was about people from transition
from one gender to the other and then
changed their mind and transition back
and this was in 2017 and it caused just
this like massive firestorm like people
were literally burning stacks of the
paper and sending me video of it just
like there are Flyers up in my
neighborhood calling the paper
transphobic my editors made transphobic
like the coffee shops that I would go to
I would walk in and there would be like
flyers calling me transphobic so there
was just a massive outcry I don't know
how many people who are mad at about the
piece actually read the piece because
the piece was not by any stretch of the
imagination transphobic it I got the
voices of lots of happily transition
people in there it was just about this
sort of small subset and a phenomenon
it's something that is happening and in
the three years since the piece is
published it's the community of D
transitioners has really emerged on
their own
they're much more visible now but this
was sort of one of the earlier pieces
about this phenomenon what attracted you
to write about that were you concerned
about maybe people transitioning too
early what did you have no agenda when
you wrote it were you kind of like just
interested in this group of people my
what I'm interested in is heretics and
people who speak out at some cost to
themselves and I found that among the D
transitioners that I spoke to so
oftentimes they felt really shunned by
their own communities the trans and
queer communities that they had
typically lived in just sort of cast
them out and they continue to speak up
about it despite the own social costs of
themselves you know it's sort of ironic
that after I read this piece the exact
same thing happened to me and I sort of
knew that it would I had talked to other
people who'd written not even critically
about trans issues but had just had
written about trans issues in a way that
didn't sort of parrot the contemporary
party line and they'd all had similar
experiences so it wasn't totally
unexpected and you know I'm so I'm a
lesbian I've lived in in queer
communities for let's see the last like
almost 20 years of my life and I did
start to notice that more and more
people were transitioning you know and
there can be a lot of a lot of reasons
for this like for one people know about
it you know it's possible now in a way
that it wasn't before but I started to
notice this like in like things rapidly
accelerated around 2016-2017 in my
community where all of a sudden you
would have a household that had maybe
you know five lesbians all transition
within the same year and I just found it
I'm like I won't lie I found it
troubling in some respects because it
just seemed like statistically this is
impossible how could this entire
community be you know be deciding that
they were that they have you know they
were born in the wrong body or or they
have gender dysphoria or whatever at the
same time it just it seemed it struck me
as trendy to be totally frank about it
and now that I know I make my money
Humpy's Rihanna I don't have to worry
about being cancelled so I can say
things like this um so that's when I
started to sort of look a little bit
more critically
what was going on and I think that my
initial instincts were have been sort of
proven proven out you know several years
later that we are seeing this very very
rapid rise and it's not something I'm
overly concerned about it's something I
observe you know and in terms of adults
adults are free to do whatever they want
if you want like to change your body I
think that is absolutely you know within
within your rights to do so I would
support anybody who does it I do think
it gets more complicated with children
though because this issue has been
studied for decades and what most
studies find is that children who report
to gender identity clinics from a young
age by the time they're adults between
60 and 90 percent of them will have
decided that they don't want to
transition and they are they're fine
living and their sex at birth which i
think is is preferable in some ways and
I know it there's a danger of saying
that like conservatives would always say
like you know wouldn't it be better if
gay people couldn't be gay but I think
the difference is that being gay only
causes you to stress if if you're
receiving that that message from from
society right I don't think there's
anything inherently that if you didn't
have sort of conservatives or Christians
or any other group not just Christians
Muslims whatever any sort of
fundamentalist group saying that what
you are is wrong I don't think it would
cause people distress inherently you
know without that sort of social
influence but gender dysphoria is is a
as a condition it's defined by distress
right and so I think we need to be
really cautious about about pediatric
transition because what the research has
found is that between 60 and 90 percent
of kids who who arrive at gender
identity clinics eventually revert to
their sex at birth feel okay about it so
their dysphoria is a leave door they
have found a different way of dealing
with their dysphoria besides taking
hormones in surgery that are you know
perm that cause permanent changes to
your body and in some side effects and
most of the children who grow out of it
end up being gay or lesbian repeated
over and over and over are these studies
controvert i would imagine a
controversial but why are they ignored
by many trans activists and people in
that community
why what is the big push for why can't
people just say listen when you're an
adult you should know I know it's a
complex issue because a lot of people
say if you have Trude that gender
dysphoria making you go through puberty
has a gender that you are not is some
form of abuse that's the argument on the
other side but why do people not take
these studies more seriously that say
many of the people who do this end up
regretting it on the other end well the
reason for this is because historically
there have been a lot of gatekeepers
when it comes to trans health care so
until relatively recently if you wanted
to transition from one sex to the other
or from one gender to the other you
would have to live as your preferred
your preferred gender sex for I think
two years minimum before you could get
hormones or surgery you had to have a
you know a lot of meetings for
therapists and doctors there's things
like this it wasn't easy and the model
of healthcare has changed so what what's
now called informed consent and in under
under these these sort of policies or
best practices informed consent
basically means that someone goes to a
doctor or therapist and says like I I'm
trans I've gender dysphoria and there's
also as a sort of interesting aside a
lot of trans activists now say that you
don't have to have gender dysphoria to
be trans but so regardless or an that
you don't have to take hormones or
surgery you just say that you're trans
and or say that you're the the Jenner
that you want to be and you know you are
without doing anything to change your
body and that's a new phenomena and I
don't think we would have seen this 10
or 15 years ago for the most part so
after this informed consent model change
all of the gatekeepers sort of
disappeared and for trans people
specifically trans adults this is a
really good thing because they did have
to go through these sort of onerous
processes to get the health care that
they needed and so now we've just sort
of gone in radically the other direction
where you just go to a doctor and you
say I would like to have you know a
double mastectomy or I'd like to have
surgery or whatever and they'll do it
you know and I think they're I think
there's you're just you're gonna see
more false positives with with not
having gatekeepers but I think there are
good reasons for trans activists
push back on the gatekeeper model
because a lot of them live through it
and are terrified that you know that
something like this would happen again
or you know future generations will have
to go through this ownerís years long
process before they're able to get
health care so that's why they push back
against these studies I think they push
back against them for valid reasons you
know they're concerned but the problem
is that the data doesn't disappear right
these lives don't disappear you can
ignore the study you can and you can you
know are you with the methodology or
whatever say the claim that the study is
is flawed in too many ways but that's
not going to change the reality which is
that the more children you have who
transition at a young age the more false
positives you're gonna have and the more
of them are gonna regret it later on
you've probably heard a lot of people
talk about how crucial their morning
routine is to setting up the proper tone
for their day whether it's waking up
early setting their goals for the day
exercise meditation or anything else but
not everybody has the time to do it all
or any of it truly with hydrant you can
jump start your morning's top perform a
week my friend I just took my friend's
bulldog my friend is a liar and a thief
and he he got me to take his bulldog for
two days because he said his bulldog
just sleeps and doesn't do anything and
the dog is a literal terrorist and the
dog rolled down the window and the car
tried to get out I mean the dog is just
I mean this is why you can't do anything
for people the dog is they said it will
yeah it'll sleep when it gets home it
just sleeps yeah yeah it just sleeps
that's what it does it's tearing
everything apart but we're talking about
the morning routine you want to kick the
coffee habit we all do it's bad for your
stomach you got to go to some cafe and
wait in line a bunch of losers it's not
good
I think he's chewing the cord now to the
air conditioning
no coffee right you want to get rid of
that we all do
we're not naturally morning people
here's the deal we all wake up with
sluggish you want to avoid that midday
slump you need to make sure you're
hydrated so much of the problem of
people that have cognitive issues it's
because you're not hydrated you're
actually dehydrated okay even if you
sleep well at night you lose water and
key nutrients throughout the night and
you're not able to put them back as you
sleep so more likely than not you
starting the day on empty so hydrant
created a refreshing electrolyte packed
drink that you mix directly into your
water to efficiently and effectively
hydrate your body each rapid hydration
mix has four essential electrolytes your
body needs sodium potassium magnesium
and zinc
there's precise balance of electrolytes
found in their mix helps your body
hydrate quickly and stay hydrated all
day 100 is packed it's backed it's
packed and it's backed ok it's backed by
research it's backed by research ok
there's people in lab coats doing the
doing the work the formula was developed
by an Oxford scientist Oxford is a top
school in the UK for many of you that
don't know because you slugs
Oxford scientists to provide perfectly
balanced efficient hydration
there's no synthetic colours stevia or
artificial sweeteners the formulas vegan
and you can choose between three
different flavors in a variety pack
Hajin starts it's just a block packet
for 30 day supply you save even more
with a monthly subscription to hydron
start every morning off of the rest of
hydration to feel better what you do
she gave it it's toy start every morning
with a rush of hydration to feel the
best at whatever you do doesn't matter
what you do contract assassin doesn't
matter unleash your inner morning person
with hydrants you're trying to drink
less coffee mm-hmm have you tried
hydrant yeah they sent us a bunch in
that loving God I'm gonna [ __ ] kill
it what do you think a hydrant I loved
it
you liked him what are the best things
about it tastes great I'm gonna cut off
its air supply what is what like I don't
really need coffee anymore hydrants a
total replacement for that it's good
right yeah yeah I like it too it goes
beyond flavoring water
yes our product is light refreshing and
clean tasting but it's our formulas
precise Pend of Kiel blend of key
electrolytes that are scientifically
formulated to jump-start the body's
natural hydration process for this
region reason it's [ __ ] late Hajduk
contains a small amount of natural cane
sugar but that's fine it's not a mistake
glucose is essential to activating the
body's hydration process you need little
glucose so if you think that a little
sugar is a mistake you're wrong yeah and
it's better to be hydrated rather than
caffeinated then you have energy and you
don't need the caffeine which dehydrates
you and you crash right there is no
crash here your body just flows
[Music]
he's really your headphone cable this is
what happens when you don't have hydrant
justsit hydrant it's not a hangover cure
but it it doesn't market itself that way
that being said hydration is important
for getting rid of hangovers so hosts
think that this is a compelling selling
point oh sorry
if you're drunk then hydrant could help
but it might not but it might don't get
out don't get down you'll break your leg
boy hydrant is a wellness and water
win-win proper hydration can bring
mental clarity mental and physical
prefer and you're gonna need one when
you take your rubber bullets to the face
can you scroll it down I think that's it
oh here we go
75% of Americans are dead I'm kidding 75
that's gonna be the ad we read in two
months
75% of Americans spend their days
dehydrated here's where we come in
launched in 2018 our team identified a
need to develop a product that rapidly
and effectively hydrates consumers our
product our dissolvable hydration mix
you just try it out you get it you put
it in you get it going you see if you
figure it out by the mix put it in the
water 25% off your first ordered ordered
tree
hydric calm / Tim use promo code Tim T I
am a checkout drink hydrant dot-com /
Tim if you went to the promo code t I am
you get 25 percent off your first order
many of us suck in the morning we are
sluggish we are grotesque we are not we
do not have mental clarity and mental
acuity I think that's the word we need
it we need to be sharp to get the jobs
that aren't there he's just like one
muscle I know never do anything for
anyone I mean isn't that really what it
is never do anything for anyone never
help anybody
hydrant is where it's at I've used it
Ben is used it you feel better you don't
crash it's a little bit of cane sugar
it's not a big deal so please if you
enjoy this show and you want a little
boost in the morning and you know you do
you know you do cuz you're not
performing adequately we've spoke to
your manager and your manager says
you're about to get out of here because
you come in with puffy eyes your face is
puffy from boozing it up like a big
booze bag because you can't deal with
the fact that you didn't you didn't
really go after any of the things you
thought you were gonna in life you're a
middle-of-the-road mediocre piece of
[ __ ] you know it and your family knows
it and their eyes burned through you
every time they see you
you're embarrassed with your friends and
you don't have any accomplishments to
put on Facebook so you just troll and
write all lives matter and try to [ __ ]
with people it's cuz you're not getting
after it and you're not getting after
cuz you wake up like a fat bloated piece
of [ __ ]
not with hydron you drink hydrant your
family and friends will love you and
you'll finally figure out what it feels
like to accomplish something
you're a goddamn zero goddamn zero and
you have been you're sure you're bad you
could get better but you need the mix
that goes into the water I'm not a snake
oil salesman and I'm not telling you
[ __ ] here's what I am telling you you
put this mix in your water you'll be
able to look at yourself in the mirror
in a few days and if you don't do that
if you always do what you always did
you'll always get what you've always
gotten it isn't that the truth isn't
that the truth isn't it the truth
hydrant like fire hydrant strength
hydrant calm /cam and enter promo code
yeah I am
is he in the shot I think he's an
absolute monster I mean he's an absolute
beast
his name's Duncan ah I love hi Jen when
when was the first time you had hydrant
last week when they gave it to us and
what happened um I started getting
better sleep because I had a seizure you
go actually I don't know if it was
related by I had a seizure right after I
tried it the first one I had in my life
Katie got real scared we called the
ambulance started shaking what happened
seriously what happened what'd you do
you get what did you do yeah I feel like
I played better golf yeah that's all you
do is play golf huh it's about all I do
yeah well good for you you know what
happened the first time I did it took
hydrant what happened I took the hydrant
out of the package and I put it in the
water and I drank the water and for a
minute I was like yeah I don't think it
did nothin but then you know what I did
I left my house
and I went I beat the [ __ ] out of a cop
I saw two cops on the street I took both
of their guns and I beat them both with
batons for twenty minutes you know long
twenty minutes is to just beat a cop
mercilessly it may be dead I don't know
but I wanted to send a message that and
you know what the message was what that
I was hydrated and I wasn't taking no
more [ __ ] you understand me it's not
just about feeling good it's what are
you doing when you feel and hydrated I
went out and I [ __ ] up a couple of
cops today we're women but it still
counts they're part of an oppressive
system you understand I did it Duncan
you're out of control
he'll just sleep they said yeah I'll
just go to sleep so I'm gonna tell you
again folks I want you to get this drink
because if you like me want to have the
energy to go out and attack female
police shrink hydrant calm /ti em promo
code t IM at checkout drink hydrant calm
slash Tim try it I mean in all
seriousness you know we do these ads to
be funny we're comedians is what we do
but in all seriousness this is a great
way to replace coffee it's a great way
to replace any type of sugar this is a
great thing to do everybody I know is
doing it and they're all happy about it
everybody I've ever met is trying this
out right now cuz I give away all the
stuff that I get here that they send me
for free and everybody feels really
happy you know if you're a big drunk and
we know you are and you wake up and you
feel like [ __ ] then at the end of the
day you can you could you could wake up
and hydrate yourself I'm gonna I'm gonna
kill him alright goodbye listen let's
talk about Mack Weldon okay we founded
Mac weld and not me but they because we
wanted to more out of the basics and
always questioned how something so
essential could be such a pain in the
ass to by the frustration was real in
our Eureka moment happened in a
department store aisle full of brands
that dominated our
draw surrounded by a mind-numbing
assortment of underwear and socks we've
realized consistent fit and quality
became a game of roulette so we decided
to take matters into our own hands we
started from scratch and engineered our
own fabric we made sure the design
process was meticulous so you can count
on the fit being the same each time we
built a world-class customer experience
the differences in the details so we
were obsessed with every stitch and seam
until we reached our definition of
perfect Mac Wheldon is better than
whatever underwear you're wearing right
now they gave it to me I have it Mac
Weldon is premier a premium man's
essential brand that believes in smart
design and premium fabrics okay Mac
Weldon likes design they like to look
nice simple shopping you know how hard
it is when you you know what happened to
me the last time I went to get underwear
what I got a rubber bullet in my face
and I got tear-gassed and I hip someone
hit me with a brick and one of the
police horses [ __ ] you know went up
and whatnots
oh what's that who needs that no one I'm
just going to the mall and people around
me or Lewton which is justifiable anger
and I but you know so I mean stop stop
leaving your house so I just went online
it got Mac Weldon underwear okay they
really value their loyal customers
that's why they've created the weld and
blue loyalty program create an account
it's totally free place in order for any
amount never pay shipping again once
you've purchased $200 worth of products
from Mac weld and not only will you
continue to receive free shipping but
you will also start saving 20% on every
order you make for the next year level 2
also grants you access to new products
before they're released to anyone else
as well as free gifts added to future
orders how great is that
I like their mission statement I like
that they built a company that likes to
make things simple but not sacrifice any
of the quality isn't that nice love it
do you I love it
so shame unis stunning you never booked
any of those commercials you went out
for remember those two years you went
out for commercials look this Starbucks
commercial what happened to it I don't
know if it ever aired up what did you do
in it I played a a guy's friend in it at
a outside of taco stand what the [ __ ]
does that have to do with Starbucks he
was holding a Starbucks cup and they
were dollying out in the rain what was
the point of the commercial what were
you I say gence
that's what Starbucks is they don't want
anybody wearing black lives matter stuff
they don't want any of their suburban
moms to get upset so what was the
commercial you were that you and
somebody else were ice agents trying to
arrest the guy that owned the taco stand
for Starbucks
Craig you should be ashamed of yourself
for 20% off your first order visit Matt
Weldon calm and enter promo code TMT I
am ok Mac well done calm em ACK wel do
and calm promo code Tim T I am I'm
telling you it's worth it you don't want
to leave your home you dummies Cove it
is spiking
it's a goddamn pandemic out there we got
violent clashes civil unrest all the
things that we were joking about six
months ago of all come true so stay home
get your underwear to your house it's
much easier in better it's Mac Weldon
calm ma c KW e LD o and.com enter promo
code t IM thank you when you see the
growth of something like non-binary
where people are identifying as queer
and they say I'm identifying is not
binary and many of them are white middle
class college students that you know
this seems to be and that's not all of
them but you know it schools like
Oberlin and Wesleyan in places like that
people are identifying as non-binary how
much of that because to me and I'm on
patreon I don't have to I can do
whatever I want a lot of it to me seems
like a identity crisis that's not really
rooted in any true gender dysphoria as
much as it's rooted in a socio-political
understanding of the world and a desire
to be maybe in a protected or a desire
to be in a group of people that's not
seen as the oppressor and how much of
this is a phase and how many of these
people grow out of that non-binary
distinction and then just live either
regular heterosexual or homosexual lives
I'm not sure that this has been studied
and I think that the phenomenon and it's
probably too young or too new to to have
good data on that but I agree with you I
find that personally I find the concept
of non-binary is incredibly regressive
because it presupposes that there that
if you're not non-binary if you're
non-binary than what am I does that make
me binary and it relies on these
stereotypes right so if you talk to
people and you say like alright I've
done this I have a lot of friends who
identify as non-binary and trans now
more actually everyday and not because
I'm meeting new people so and I've had
these conversations my friends so so
explain to me like what does it feel
like to be non-binary and they'll say
and I do say is both the single area and
the plural in this case well you know
sometimes I when I wake up I I feel like
a man and sometimes I feel like a woman
all right well what does that mean or I
feel like neither what does that mean
well sometimes I want to wear masculine
clothes and sometimes I want to wear FM
clothes and so to me that's just
reinforcing stereotypes that I think
both men and women would be better off
rejecting and so that's my problem with
with the idea of non-binary I think it
just reinforces this it reinforces the
binary and this like very sort of ironic
twist and I think I'd like to be totally
Frank I think it's very trendy it is
trendy there's like it I'm sure that
lots of people would get mad at me for
saying this but it is undeniably trendy
and it you know it's like identity is
such a huge thing now and like when I
was when I was a teenager I don't think
we ever talked about identity we talked
about sort of a clique that you were in
and a style that you had and I think
there's a lot of overlap like you know
we had the goth kids and all kids and
the jocks and the rednecks or whatever
and now you have you just like adding up
no we have non binaries and then I have
Indies and activists and the anarchists
and you know yeah and the asexuals and
the a romantics and the furries and it's
just this like we just have more labels
than I ever would have imagined
wrote an article about furries I've
written so many articles I don't need
you doing this I'm sure I'm sure that I
did at some point what is the furry
community and how are they helping black
lives matter the furry community so
furry it's gonna be a couple different
things the most interesting furries are
the furries who dressed up like stuffed
animals and have sex with each other
like in the suits right in their first
days so that's what I've always thought
of as very sad but there's awesome it's
now it has gone from sort of a kink to
an identity and not all for user have
sex in their suits not all furries or
king stirs and not all King stirs are
furries
but it what started out as I can't guy
think has become much more of an
identity that people take seriously the
great thing about phrase is that they
tend to have like anime avatars in there
and their BIOS are like cartoon drawings
of themselves in their first suit so
it's a really good signal of who not to
take seriously
yeah my friend Nick Malin made a very
interesting point once about a lot of
the people that you see it like
identifying as non-binary a lot of them
it's either not only anime avatars but
they're kind of like nerds they're very
they're they seem to be over invested in
like these mythological worlds I think
that's why JK Rowling's treason hit them
so hard dude I know I have like I have
an ex-girlfriend who who called me out
when I rent this D trans piece like
excommunicated me from her life we were
on good terms but just like was done
with me after I wrote this piece and she
has about six Harry Potter tattoos
obviously like at this point I can't ask
her how she's feeling but I just wonder
how quickly she made the appointment to
get all of her tattoos covered up yeah
what do you think it is what is the
overlap there between nerds and people
that have some type of sexual identity
crisis and I mean nerds not like nerds
like people that are coders but I mean
people that you know whatever play Magic
the Gathering like are love these
mythological worlds also a lot of them
there seems to be an overlap with people
that have sexual identity issues if you
could stipling if you could guess what
that overlap would be or postulate what
it might be what do you think it is okay
this
pure speculation so I don't know if
anybody has studied this I have no no
like good data on this just pure
speculation so I think there might be
two things and the first one I say with
a little bit of hesitation because I
feel like I could get me in trouble but
I'm gonna do it anyway
I think the first connection is autism
so there's a really high and this is not
so much about furries or fantasy worlds
that it's getting good we're getting rid
we're getting we're getting close to the
meat the meat is tender closer to the
bone keep going ok so there has been
research on natal females so what we
typically think of is like teen girls
who transition to either male or
non-binary or whatever so this
population has spiked in recent years
and there's some the there's some
overlap between NATO females who the
concept is called rapid onset gender
dysphoria so it's basically a population
who doesn't have a history a pediatric
history of gender dysphoria but sort of
spends a lot of time online and decides
at some point that that he or she are
they're trans um and like surprisingly
high percentage and I don't know the
numbers doesn't have my head and I don't
know if anybody does actually but there
is some overlap with people on the
autism spectrum disorder so I think that
might be part of it people who maybe are
more drawn to the online world who who's
social skills are making human
connections face to face is in sort of
their primary way of interacting with
the world and when you spend a lot of
time in online communities it's just
like any other community what's
happening in the community rubs off on
you so I mean I think I think we're in
the midst of a social contagion in terms
of trans death it's probably not
something I would have said that if I
still worked at the stranger and and you
know had an editor who could yell at me
for it but I think anybody who's really
been observing this would say that it's
obvious what explains the rise in autism
oh that I have no idea well I mean I
probably I've done a little bit of
research on this and I think probably
well vaccines obviously but it's not
that there's a do you think that you
know okay I don't think I don't think
that's right no there's a I think Tikes
you had my audit you had my audience and
you just lost
just lost him it's a it's a fickle group
when you said Oh a trans people are
autistic they were like they press
subscribe on your patreon they press
donate and then when you said autism
didn't come from vaccines their finger
went off the button so you gotta be very
careful but so if it's not vaccines and
I'm not saying it's vaccines what do I
know I was vaccinated I'm fine you know
what more or less more or less what do
you think it could be oh I think I
probably died like better diagnostic
tools I mean it's possible that people
are I did see okay there's a book called
by Johann Hari called I'm forgetting the
name of it but the latest book by Johann
Hari who's a journalist wrote a book
about the causes of the root causes of
depression and anxiety
specifically depression and if I asked
like most people on the street what
causes depression what I think they're
going to tell me is there's a chemical
imbalance right and it turns out that
that's not true according according to
Harry that really that was like the idea
that there's a serotonin imbalance in
your head and that's the reason you're
depressed is based on like a very small
study in the 1960s that was never
replicated what he argues and I'm not an
expert on this so this I'm just like
repeating his fighting so if anybody
gets mad about this yell at him and
instead of me what he argues is that
depression and anxiety are much more a
response to living in a disconnected
world people are depressed because our
lives are shitty and it's actually a
natural response and there is evidence
that SSRIs things like you know um pack
solar or lorazepam or whatever these are
these drugs that are used to treat
depression anxiety are mostly effective
as placebos and so I bring this up in
the context of autism because there's
one line in his book that I don't know
if this is true please like this is this
is just like anybody who's listening to
this research this yourself before you
take this at face value he says that
there is some evidence that there may be
a correlation between taking birth
control and autism I mean I'm sorry I'm
sorry
not taking birth control about taking
SSRIs and autism so we've seen a spike
in and the uses of antidepressants at
the same time that we've seen a spike
and incidences of autism I want to I
want to
I wanted like real like just I am NOT an
expert on this so nobody consider what
I'm saying I think you say here's don't
take the medicine folks you don't need
it my mother who's a schizophrenic she
probably needs it she well she I mean to
be honest the way the world is unfolding
I'm I wonder if we're gonna have to go
apologize to my mother because
everything she's saying is happening she
said there were people you know um
listen it's very interesting right when
you talk about anxiety and depression
because a lot of people have this again
as an identity like I grew up with
genuine mental illness my mother was
genuinely paranoid schizophrenic
she thought people were following her
she thought members of the family were
stealing from her I'm she had nothing to
take [ __ ] beanie baby she thought out
she said it Christmas dinner once Elvis
might have been her father or her father
might have been a big celebrity I can't
see that I mean if you flipped your hair
back you could be hip gyration
yes they're not bad they're not great
but so I was very skeptical of what I
when I when I looked at and I saw people
that were diagnosing themselves with
anxiety off Instagram like they were you
know so it seems like the rise in these
not to say that these things don't exist
but like again it feels very tied to the
need to have an identity and a way to
put yourself in a box and say hey I
suffer from this I suffer you know a lot
of men and comedy straight white men in
comedy have to go out now and say
they're anxious or they depress I
struggle with depression I'm anxious
even though I'm white I'm anxious I go
through things too so it is interesting
to talk about that and of course now
these pharmaceutical companies are
making billions of dollars marketing
solutions to these problems right
I do think anxiety and depression are
real but I think that the cause might
not be what we have always consumed the
cause to be these chemical imbalances
and and that's where I've sort of found
out but I do think you're on to
something about you know you're put
becoming your identity and also it seems
undeniable that victimhood culture is
sort of very and also be poor diet right
I mean right white you know things like
my least favorite thing to do in the
world is exercise I know that if I
exercise I would be less anxious and
less depressed but that's hard it is
hard to get up and like move your body
and sweat and it's not fun it doesn't
feel good so what is easier going out
and doing these things that actually
will make you feel better about the
world or taking a pill I can totally see
the appeal of taking the pill it's just
easier but I mean there's also lots of
evidence that the pills are mostly
effective as placebos and they don't
work long-term
you know people have to continue upping
the dosage of the of their medication
all the time and there are really
serious side effects which is the which
is the problem you know if you were just
taking a sugar pill and you're it
relieved your depression anxiety it
wouldn't have any side effects but if
you're taking something that you know
make sure boobs grow bigger or smaller
or makes you go bald or makes RuPaul
shrink or whatever you know whatever it
is well that's a problem why do you
think I mean I do think people are
genuinely anxious and depressed because
we live in a world that is actually
safer in some respects than I've ever
been you know 2020 aside but we still
live in these ways that are pretty
unnatural for humans you know especially
in the midst of a pandemic like how many
people have been stuck in their
apartments alone for three months and
now you can go out and protest so that's
that's like your get out get out of
apartment free card but just humans
aren't meant to live like this and it
and it makes us kind of crazy and we're
also not meant to spend all of our time
staring at [ __ ] screens all day no
we're not what do you think what's
what's happened in academia and the type
of ideas that have thrived in the
academic space for more than a decade
but certainly a really contentious in
the last decade are now bleeding out
into the media you're seeing it at the
New York Times with the editor James
Bennett the editorial editor whatever
resigned because they published an
article by Tom cotton Senator Tom cotton
with a position which was if the cops
can't contained chaos got to bring in
the military at the time they published
the article I think that in polls had
you know support of 58% of people were
supporting Tom cotton
and they ran it in the new york times
there's been essentially like a coup you
see it's happening in James Bennett
resigned there are other newsrooms
reportedly Andrew Sullivan gay writer at
The New Yorker cannot publish an order
here Andrews at New York magazine New
York magazine he cannot publish an
article about the riots and every
article that he does publish has to be
vetted a bunch of times to make sure
that it doesn't you know trigger people
so a lot of these ideas that were
confined to classrooms and confined to
the universities have now bled out into
the media and people are saying you know
it's a matter of time before they enter
the government are they enter the court
system what are these ideas how would
you because they've been called a lot of
things right Jordan Peterson has said
it's post modernism a lot of people said
it's neo Marxism some people say it's
the excesses of political correctness
what how would you qualify these ideas
and why is there spread seemingly you
know why are they now so popular and and
and and why don't more people recognize
that they these ideas inherently lead to
a more divisive society with more
violence than the one that we have now
which is which is what I see I see that
when I read were the way that you know
people want people to interact and the
amount of stresses you're putting on
people in these social situations that
are of different races and different
genders the attack on humor which is
huge which is too thin by the way nobody
in the Ivy League realizes this because
they've never had a shitty job when you
work a shitty low wage minimum rate a
minimum wage job the jokes that you do
to each other are race jokes their base
level humor that makes people laugh
because the only things you guys have in
common and the only things that you can
really isolate about each other are are
characteristic so if you're fat or if
you're gay I haven't been either of
those two things but if you are Irish
I've suffered for that so people end up
and in the Ivy League or in the text you
know companies or places like that Dave
never worked a shitty job where
everyone's kind of miserable and you're
blowing off steam so I just look at the
way that they want to configure the
world and I say this leads to more
alienation more isolation and ultimately
more violence I think you're right there
is a lot of argument about what to call
this moment or the genesis of this
moment I mean as you mentioned a lot of
this comes from academia and they sort
of postmodern and critical race studies
critical you know jet critical study or
CRC excuse me theory Studies series lots
of things that cannot be proved they can
only be postulated and you have seen
this really break down in the past or
break out into the mainstream over the
past couple of weeks since the murder of
George Floyd which is frankly a bit a
little bit refreshing to see because
I've been talking and bitching and
warning people about the excesses of the
social justice left and what's happening
on colleges for years and people have
said things like it's just you know it's
campus it's college kids being college
kids college kids demanding trigger
warnings trying to deep platform
speakers basically rejecting all notions
of free speech and free expect as free
expression and diversity of thought just
this narrowing of liberal values and I
don't mean liberalism democratic was
sort of enlightenment values and we've
been seeing this those of us have been
paying attention have been seeing this
for years and now it has broken open
into the mainstream which is in some
ways a relief and I think you're right
this something that started in academia
has really spread out and it's
everywhere in media there as you
mentioned Bennett got forced to
essentially step down from New York
Times for basically publishing a
problematic op-ed by a sitting u.s.
senator
there have been firings over the past
couple weeks and or the past week or so
at bon appetit refinery29 the
Philadelphia Inquirer a journalist that
the CBC was fired for saying that inward
as she was quoting somebody she was you
know it's the same thing that happened
to Papa John last year where you can't
say this word even to quote somebody the
second city's sat down CrossFit there's
been lots and lots of these firings I
think probably the most egregious one
was a guy named David Shore who tweeted
an article it was this not an article it
was a study that had been conducted by a
black man that looked at public
perception of violent versus nonviolent
approach
in the 1960s and what he found is that
violent protests tended to make voters
drift to the raid nonviolent protests
increased Democratic turnout and so this
basically analysts tweeted this out and
there's a massive outcry a study by a
black man so he tweets us out there's a
massive outcry he got fired from his job
right and so this is gonna continue
happening someone in my DMS refer to
what's happening right now is me too for
microaggressions and I think that's very
apt way of putting it and one of the
parallels is that you're seeing these
purges in the same industries that
affected the me two that were affected
during me too so media tech academia
these sort of elite institutions mostly
dominated by upper upper middle class
and wealthy people where you're not
seeing it as much and where I don't
think you're going to see it as much is
in you know in the working class right
so restaurant the places where you're
actually more likely to be you know to
experience actual racism not
microaggressions but actual overt racism
or overt sexual harassment and this is
not to minimize the experiences that
people have you know have gone through
it sort of the upper echelon of American
culture but you know I worked at I
worked in cafes I worked at restaurants
I was a dishwasher like that is actually
where you get sexually harassed and that
is actually where you hear like overtly
racist comments and I do not think
you're going to be seeing these purges
and that and that sort of class in sort
of the underclass and I also don't think
they will the underclass will benefit
and as much as sort of the upper the
upper class as well from this early some
people will benefit is the excesses of
the kind of gangster capitalism that we
have now where you have lots of wealthy
institutions and corporations avoiding
taxes and essentially creating a
parallel world for themselves to live in
they are now using the language of
social justice to communicate their
commitment to changing the world but
largely it's a static and that is still
they're still running out the back door
with a pot with a bag of money right
there's a lot of irony and seeing
somebody like Jeff Bezos like lauded as
a hero for making a pro black lives
matter statement when I get
as actually gives a [ __ ] about black
lives he could you know make sure that
his black employees get bathroom breaks
at his fulfillment centers or healthcare
you know same thing with companies like
uber and lyft in all of these these tech
company or the NFL any of these
companies that have you know come out
and made their statement but it also
right now the pressure to conform is so
high that it is not surprising to me at
all that brands are jumping on this for
one not doing it would be terrible PR
there's been a list circulating among
like in the LA theater scene like a
crowdsourced list that notes which which
theater companies or whatever people in
this in this field haven't come out and
made a you know a pro black lives matter
statement and so if you're worried it's
been a New York so maybe that's there is
not feeling up to up to the ruling class
other than the paying the lip service
what are they are they're people right
now sitting in the smoke-filled rooms
going this is good for us
keep them divided let's feed the flames
are they like hey let's figure out a way
you know I'm talking about the people
that are at Davos two people go to the
Bilderberg Group the people that own
these media companies that are you know
government intelligence you know
national security apparatus chrome deep
state call them whatever
permanent political class of people
largely unelected there because they
have a lot of money what are they doing
what is their what are they gonna try to
do how do they are they gonna try to
wield this anger that you see right now
I have to admit I don't have any
connections in the deep State so I'm not
a I'm not sure I'd be able to really
answer that question but you know
historically how many of these protest
groups have been co-opted by the FBI I
mean look at coin type Pro I mean look
at all of these things right right I
mean we know that a lot of times things
are pushed in and and maybe we don't
even need you know the infiltration
anymore because people are just ready to
push things further than they should go
by themselves but like you know you have
a lot of billionaires in this country
you have a lot of wealth and you have a
lot of people what are they
if you could speculate what do you think
they are feeling at this precise moment
are they seeing things come are the
wheels coming off or are they not coming
off and are we all overreacting because
we're paying such high you know hyper
close attention all this I think there
are a couple of different issues here I
mean what are they feeling I bet some of
them are feeling a lot of white guilt if
they are anything like the people who
I'm following in my and my social media
feeds and the friends that I'm talking
to a lot of white guilt probably um will
that actually change anything like Jeff
Bezos feel some white guilt is he
actually gonna change the you know
policies about Amazon I don't think so I
don't think that he will you know I
think that the reason that companies and
brands are engaging this is because to
be perceived as racist is will kill your
brand I have no idea what the people
pulling the strings at Davos or behind
the scenes think of any of this I mean
you make it sound like they're you know
sort of they've got devil horns sticking
out of their heads and I don't and I
don't know though that's true it sounds
a little conspiratorial to me and you
could tell me right you said devil horns
I didn't think of the horns what I'm
saying is that the what I've read about
the fine folks at these places are the
ones that frequented little st. James
the ones that cut the sweetheart deal
for Jeffrey Epstein the people that you
know get us into Wars all over the place
that we need not be in I'm a little
skeptical I'm just I'm curious as to
what they think about this that's what
I'm not saying they all have devil horns
but I'm saying they have entrenched
interests right you know and you wonder
in a period of chaos like this what they
feel I wonder if they've soured on Trump
I wonder if they cuz they're not a
monolith by the way I mean nobody that's
read about this stuff that's saying
thinks that these people are monolith
but they do exist I mean the reality is
like you know these things are real
Obama gate is real Brennan and clapper
these people are real you know they have
interests they have the the capability
to do lots of things behind the scenes
and I'm just I'm do you and it's a
question for you as a journalist do you
ignore that dimension of power
completely do you see
that dimension of power is just a
fantasy of Yahoo's on Twitter you don't
give any credence to the idea that there
are very wealthy very powerful people
that operate behind the scenes no I
think that's probably likely true it's
not something that I follow and probably
because you know I'm not an
investigative journalist and that
particularly problem I mean you're being
cancelled at the CIA hijacking your car
I mean I mean what yeah I'm more worried
about is okay so I'm worried about a
couple things I'm worried that the
protest now are gonna lead to a backlash
in which Donald Trump gets elected and
I'm worried about that not because like
I like I don't think I think Tom
derangement said in Israel I don't think
I personally suffer for it but I do
think like I do think orange man is bad
and not because like and I actually
think that the president has too much
power so if you have a total bungling
idiot in the White House and he isn't
actually able to get anything done I'm
like I'm okay with that I mean they just
told a black news anchor on Fox that
Lincoln may not did you see that yeah
where he goes
Lincoln late what Lincoln did was mixed
freeing the slaves he does you don't
really know and then the black anchor on
Fox News had to go well we're free and
he goes yes you free no I mean the
United States he's also doing a rally at
Tulsa Oklahoma that's the scene of a
massacre black time he's doing it on
Juneteenth are all of these things you
know I mean I don't know I mean is this
guy I think I think it's red meat I
think he's just trying to rile up his
base I think he's trying to capitalize
on what happens now on what's happening
now and from you know from like not even
nevertrump errs but Republicans who have
been more supportive of Trump
they have criticized them the sort of
intellectual Republicans have criticized
his handling of this crisis and the
pandemic they have criticized him I
don't know that they represent the base
and Trump needs his base to come out and
he doesn't need him to come out
everywhere but he needs them to come out
and a few select districts and a few
select States to win you know because of
our electoral college to win just a few
states and he'll have the election and
I'm very terrified that the backlash is
going to lead to that that's
I'm also scared and not equally scared
but I am also scared concerned let's say
that if Joe Biden wins Joe Biden is not
woke right and Joe Biden he's you know
he's old as [ __ ] he I sort of all of his
like his his gas and his missteps I sort
of like them because what they show me
is that he is intentionally not
politically correct but I think right
now the pressure to appoint people to
his cabinet who are representative of
these sort of illiberal liberals I think
we're gonna see that and so my concern
is that Biden gets elected and he
appoints Robyn D'Angelo Julie the you
know the new like department of
reparations or something like that
hopefully he wouldn't appoint a white
woman to do that but these sort of
critical theorists that we are just
talking about I am worried about that
being intransigent government and you're
already seeing this in education so
education system specifically in cities
like New York and in Seattle I'm sure
it's this Avenue in San Francisco
probably LA sort of the big metro areas
but all over the world they teach this
critical race theory that is basically
it's essentialist in nature and it
focuses everything on race right and I
don't actually think that that's good
for the Republic I think the more you
focus on race the more you're going to
have resentful white people responding
to that in a negative way because people
don't like to feel guilty because of
their race they just don't and so I'm
concerned about about Biden getting into
the office and appointing a bunch of
like you know University cuckoos who are
then gonna be dictating policy like
Elizabeth Warren you remember did you
watch the lbgtq Town Hall last year I'm
ashamed to say I did not oh well you
really missed that it was only about
nine hours long and there was a lot of
like crazy rhetoric like at one point
there was a lot of like outbursts and
protests which was sort of funny because
mostly was happening during mayor Pete
the one gay guy who did that like him so
these politicians like at one point and
you probably heard this Elizabeth Warren
said that if she is elected she would
appoint or she would that she would
allow a nine-year-old trans kid they
Jacob who was in the audience to vet the
next Secretary of Education and maybe
that was just rhetoric I think it's in
like utter insanity for one thing it's a
campaign ad for Donald Trump but it's
also just stupid on its face right we
don't let children we don't let children
dictate who's going to be the next
Secretary of Education and I don't care
how trans they are or how cute they are
we just don't do that so that's my fear
is that this current moment is going to
force Biden to adopt some of the
identitarian they're like far left
identitarian policies that some of his
opponents like Warren and Castro and and
occurr inherence basically everyone else
even marianne williamson we're
advocating for that I don't think Biden
really believes in but just the pressure
has built the momentum has built and
even if it doesn't reflect the you know
the dominant perspective of the American
voter but it does reflect as a dominant
perspective of the media Twitter the
loudest most powerful voices what is the
endgame for the critical race Theory the
people that push this narrative what is
their endgame what would they like
society to look like if they had their
way I think they would they want power I
think that's that's the endgame and this
makes it sound more sort of duplicitous
that I think and I think it really is I
think a lot of these people are true
believers there are anti-racist and
anti-racist is not may not race it's a
particular actual set of values that are
sort of very essential in nature that
whiteness is something that needs to be
overcome
what is whiteness somebody explain to me
I don't know what Zach no idea yeah it's
more than just it's more than just your
ethnicity it's this it's this I guess
this thing inside of all of us maybe
it's like a soul that it's connected to
white supremacy the original sin all of
this rhetoric is incredibly religious
right but the difference between I think
what's happening now sort of great
awoken in an actual religion is that
religion most religions have some
mechanism for for reform or
reconciliation or grace and this doesn't
exist in this current dogma so I you
know I've never taken a class in
whiteness studies maybe I should do that
maybe I'll go back to school and become
a diversity trainer if my podcast
doesn't work out I've never
told you this but when I was a young boy
I loved cereal and my best friend was a
kid named Paul okay why are you laughing
because it seems like you're making this
up oh it's it's not what's happening
right now I'm sharing something is for a
deep and personal to me and that's why
it's taking me a little bit to get it
out but I think you assuming that I'm it
she shows the type of person you are
okay what did I say then was I big ball
Paul was my best friend that I've ever
had
he was a good kid and he believed in the
same values and ideals and I believed in
freedom democracy the markets and Paul
had a tough home life it was a hard life
it was it was not easy you know his
parents had a rough marriage and they
were fond of the bottle and they liked
to drink
they liked to throw a few back and then
they would mercilessly beat him and that
was tough for him but but there were
good times
you know there were good times do you
know what he loved what he loved cereal
he loves he really he would come over to
my house black and blue and bleedin and
and I would say hey hey let's have a
bowl Lucky Charms and he would love it I
mean it would take his mind off the
beatings I mean they used to go at him
I mean there was I went to call from you
know you go call for somebody like we
have friends you go can I call for my
friend you know
practical yeah and then you go knock at
the door hey Paul play I mean one time I
went and they they both had hockey
sticks out and in the backyard they were
just going at him I thought he was dead
because he was no longer moving they
were just hitting him with the hockey
sticks and they were making a game out
of it I don't know weird people
not without they were fun you know not
without throat they were characters but
they were just you know hitting what
appeared to be his lifeless body with
hockey sticks in the backyard I don't
even know where they got the sticks even
playing hockey
it was a horrible thing to see it was a
horrible thing to see now when they saw
me they looked at me and they didn't
stop that was even weirder they saw me
and then they just kept beating him and
hitting him with sticks and I I said
whoa and I went up to him eventually
they David they stopped and I went off
to him and I carried him he was I
carried him you know like Christ when he
went off the cross I carried him back to
my house and I kinda I nursed him back
to life with Lucky Charms now he's dead
now uh his parents cooked him and ate
him
now that is neither here nor there
because if he was alive today he would
want to eat Lucky Charms because they
reminded him of the good times in his
childhood of which they were admittedly
few and but he wouldn't want the sugars
he wouldn't want it he like kept himself
good so he would take he would get magic
spoon which is a new cereal company
that's discovered a way to recreate your
favorite childhood cereals with zero
sugar twelve grams of protein and only
three net grams of carbs in each serving
it tastes too good to be true with magic
spoon you can indulge in an array of
classic flavors cocoa fruity frosted and
blueberry fruitiest is is the best one
it tastes like you know Froot Loops but
get a variety pack taste all fours he
was good for you magic spoon spent over
a year working with the best food
scientists and chefs in the world one
time they were they put his head in a
fish tank and I didn't even understand
it but they put his head in a fish tank
and he they turned them upside down they
were like giving him swirling a fish
tank and they they were doing it so hard
they broke the glass everything it was
like what did he do to deserve that you
know what I mean but no matter what they
did time after time the best that's the
biggest smile he had no teeth one once
and I had to grind up the Lucky Charms
and feed them to him like a paste but he
loves cereal if that dog if that dog
does not go to [ __ ] bed
I'm watching my friend's dog right now
this is it I'm gonna kill him my friend
is a [ __ ] dude he [ __ ] snow balled
me dude and I should never I will never
take this dog again yeah this dog is a
literal terrorist and and I I my friend
and his wife were are flying to Tahoe
for the weekend I took their dog which
they lied said as I could well
well-trained dog it's absolutely not
trained and I hope their plane crashes
by the way I did it just get out through
your door I don't think so maybe the
giving up magic spoon comm slash Tim
Dylan grabbing a variety pack it's magic
spoon calm / Tim Dylan you got to grab a
variety pack okay
use the code Tim Dylan for free shipping
one time at Christmas they gave him a
Christmas present and he opened it up
and they'd both [ __ ] in a box and they
made him eat it and he almost died from
eating their [ __ ] so again you know hey
you know it's crazy they weren't the
worst parents magic spoon dot-com / Tim
Dylan grabbed a variety pack do it for
me and do it for my dead friend who
loves cereal whose parents beat him to
death
Tim and Adam never got charged are still
free claim II ran away we know better
magics boon com / Tim Dylan free
shipping thank you
the Tim Dylan show is brought to you by
the weed whacker from manscaped I use
this the other day listen up fellas
because we have a new mask a product to
learn manscape just released the weed
whacker nose and ear hair trimmer take a
look in the mirror and I use a regular
one for that your dick but the other one
is good to take a look at the mirror and
I guarantee you'll see hair sticking out
of your face holes that's because you
know of course with a quarantine and
everything else nose hairs gross nobody
likes it got to get rid of that nose
hair so the cocaine goes up smooth the
weed whacker uses skin safe technology
which helps present prevent Nicks and
snags let's not let's change NICs right
now please just say snags who's writing
this trying to get me get me in trouble
it's got 9,000 rpm motor powered 360
degree rotary dual blade system its
intelligently contour design enhances
the trimming experience manscaped is the
best waterproof use it in the shower for
easy use of cleaning the only nose hair
trimmer on the market with a powerful
and rechargeable lithium-ion battery
that lasts for up to 90 minutes of use
have you ever pulled your nose hair out
with your fingers this might hurt worse
than nicking your balls manscaped is
making whacking your weeds at time to
look forward to delivering maximum
confidence while providing hygiene yes
you will get replaceable blade every two
months to keep your weed-whacking time
clean and enjoyable 79% of partners
polled admitted that long nose hair is a
major turnoff who are those other 21%
those are the ladies you need a woman's
like I actually prefer nose hair and she
goes I also like to get punched in the
face because there's something masculine
about a guy that has nose hair and
doesn't let me run my mouth if you know
what I mean I like a man with nose hair
who grabs me by the back of the hair and
says how about you shut the [ __ ] up
my last boyfriend had nose hair you know
what he also had big hands and when I
would act up he'd put him on me and calm
me down it's nothing like getting
smacked in a crowded macy's look fellas
I did that one time
upgrade your manscaping routine with the
weed whacker I liked manscaped I usually
the other one and the weed whackers good
to get 20% off free shipping with the
code Tim weed and manscaped comm TI MW
easy if you need a nose hair trimmer
this is it and you do also get the dick
thing - that's great - the manscaped is
great you do not NIC I used it the other
day you don't Nick you're you know it's
great and it's specially if you're a fat
person you don't even know what you're
shaving down there you just have to
shave something so the other ones you
just end up bloody and it's bad but
man's cape you just you could shave it's
all good 20% off with free shipping
manscape com use the code T IM w ee d
what are you waiting for go whack your
weeds how do you see this as a way what
is your feeling about the people that
say we're trying to end capitalism what
is the what what is that you know in
terms of you know people are I mean
there's obviously all of the the you
know the contradictions you have to
breeze past your tweeting that from an
iPhone your tweeting that in a Starbucks
or whatever it is but you know we most
people realize they the present form of
capitalism is unsustainable right so how
how serious are these people they talk
about reforming it and are they the
people to reform it and how do you
reform it you know with more than
slogans my perspective on this has
changed in recent years I probably would
have called myself a socialist
five or six years ago but what I've
realized is that the the version of
socialism that we think of as like the
ideal socialism so like northern
European democratic socialism right
it's socialism sure like there's high
taxes people are taking care there's a
welfare state but then there's the other
kind of socialism like Marxism communism
sort of socialism adjacent in which the
state the state controls the means of
production right the state the state
controls the businesses and I see
nothing in America's recent history that
shows to me that the state would be
better at maintaining and producing
goods and and having functional
companies then then free market
capitalists are so I've changed my mind
about this a little bit I find myself
much more sympathetic to free-market
values than I did before that said
you're right I mean capitalism as we
know it is deeply flawed but to me I
think what you could do is you know
regulate capitalism a little better
things like to me I care deeply about
the environment that sort of I care more
about the planet the people in some
respects and so you know stricter
controls on things like emissions you
know there are arguments to be made that
all people and companies respond better
to incentives than they do penalties and
I think that that is something that
should be explored but I think socialism
for a lot of people especially young
people it's just become a sort of a
signifier right so you put like a little
rose emoji in your Twitter bio and now
you're a socialist and and what you want
is like you know you want free health
care which I think I think we should
have a single-payer health care system I
don't know that we should totally
dismantle the private health care system
before we before we do that you know
they want free education and lots of
them have student loans they want free
[ __ ] essentially which I totally I want
free [ __ ] too I sympathize with that but
I don't know how much they have thought
about like you know Donald Trump is our
president the folks the federal
government has and state governments
have shown over and over again that they
are unable to manage industry as well as
the free market is you know just things
like ventilators or like in Washington
State where I live you know we have this
unemployment system it's antiquated you
know difficult to use people a colleague
of mine just got his first unemployment
check he's been on a play for three
months just got his first unemployment
check this week you know the system ISM
isn't functional and it's these
government systems that aren't working
I think like people talk about
capitalism one of the major issues that
I have with it is this this parallel
world where wealthy people can evade
taxes and they can and this happens all
over the world you know it's not
necessarily nature the way that this
system functions where you can just take
money and dump it into real estate and
in cities without you know putting your
name on it you can you do it through a
shell corporation it drives up the cost
of of real estate in these cities like
New York London it prices everybody else
out you know people have people like
their home they like where they grew up
these areas have histories and they have
and they're you know the relationships
that people have to these places are
deep and complex so when you just allow
a group of billionaires from all over
the world turn these cities into money
laundering schemes it fills people with
the type of anxiety that then gets
redirected in a very unhealthy place
whereas it's race resentment or it's
paranoia or it's conspiracy mongering
and I think a lot of that starts with
people seeing places they loved kind of
be taken over and being used for you
know international criminals really to
to stash money and that's one example of
of the system but the other example of
the system is like you know the amount
of money and its impact on our political
system is absurd I mean I mean obviously
when you have things like you know
massive corporations donating to
senators or whatever like we need to be
concerned about how this is impacting
the roads but you have someone like
Michael Bloomberg right how many
billions of dollars did he spend on
Lines campaign he [ __ ] lost you know
like yeah like the Koch brothers you
know right and like so I'm not like who
spent Joe Biden spent only Koch brothers
sit out 2016 didn't have a war chest of
like 80 million dollars hmm wrote about
don't think I don't think these they
supported Donald Trump they didn't
support the president but they
to local election things like that when
it comes to at least the presidential
the presidential race I'm not convinced
that these massive influx infusions of
cash whether it's Bernie Sanders style
five dollars at a time or its you know
Michael Bloomberg sending like spending
his own portion or if it's you know big
money PACs I'm not gonna may not matter
as much as the ability to manipulate
things on a local even state level sure
so I think that like that concerns
people like me where I'm not a Marxist
and I don't believe that the government
is gonna be good at producing goods but
I'm saying if you don't regulate people
and none of it has to do with America
this is my other thing with capitalism
like we've married the capitalism in
America so closely together it's like
this is the way we do it but how many of
these people don't give a [ __ ] when a
city like Detroit collapses
how many people don't care that the Rust
Belt of America is it's been hollowed
out they're dealing now with an opioid
addiction how many these people care
about the southside of Chicago and the
shootings that are happening there or do
these people maintain residences all
over the world and their loyalty is to
an economic architecture more so than an
actual country that to me seems
unsustainable because I don't want to
live in a technocratic surveillance
state which is I think what these people
want I think they wanted to treat peep I
want to think they want to strip people
of rights surveil them and and then
they're gonna have all the best real
estate you know you drive up the
California coast all of the prime real
estate is owned all of the good real
estate if you like the environment you
know go to you know the Puget Sound to
tell me how much of that has been taken
over by insanely wealthy powerful people
but you also have to I mean you do have
a point I mean in places like Vancouver
Vancouver BC was for a while the Muslim
Marxist to fascist multiple times
because we've got a Mac we maximize it
and if you want to do well at this you
and Dad who's that Jesse Pinkman who you
ready with but the point is if you want
to do that you gotta Aussie you gotta
give him a look give him a right then
you give him a left because everyone who
listens wants of all my audience wants
to get teen who goes in the guillotine
it depends okay well yeah I don't think
anybody should go in the guillotine
enjoy poorhouse okay I'm gone okay but
there's also so I think you're right
about this I mean internet foreign
speculation is a big deal on local
markets I mean and Seattle they they've
tried to cut down on foreign buyers
buying essentially second third condos
because you end up with cities where you
know basically you have these you know
multi-million dollar high-rises per unit
and nobody living in them right it's
just it's money marketing but one of the
reasons there's a housing crisis in the
United States is because it's just a
supply and demand issue right so there's
just not enough housing well why would
people be why would developers want to
build cheap single-family homes when
they can build these massive sky Rises
or whatever it's just more expensive
places so i think you're right i mean is
regulation the better way to get there
or our market incentives is a better way
to get there i mean to me that's the
question between social capital tax
abatements to luxury condo developers
aren't we giving i mean that activity
like you know just like the insane tax
breaks that they get so it's like some a
company like Foxconn don't get to go to
the place like what's Wisconsin and and
bring in 500 jobs or whatever you know
and like I live in in a city with I
don't know how many billionaires live in
Seattle I mean there's the [ __ ] ton
of them and we don't have an income tax
in the state it is unconstitutional to
have an income tax in the state which is
exactly why Amazon and this is why they
live here and George Jeff Bezos
initially wanted to house Amazon on a
Native American reservation because the
tax thought they have even you know even
more relaxed tax laws on reservations
and they do in places like Seattle which
I was just like incredibly regressive
but that's the thing like last year
there was a huge debate in Seattle about
instituting a head tax right so there's
no so we have incredibly high property
taxes and incredibly high sales tax and
we'll have levies all the time because
there's no there's this is an incredibly
wealthy city and there's no income tax
anywhere in the state and no capital
gains tax which is it's a constant it's
in the Constitution right you have to
amend the Constitution to change this so
the city has tried to do little kind of
workaround so they were going to
Institute what what's called a head tax
or a per employee tax on on businesses
and so Amazon was so opposed to this
that Jeff Bezos just like it was like
I'm not going to build another Tower
there
the midst of building a tower we're just
not gonna build this tower we're gonna
move we're going he was going to take
his ball and go home in it which he can
do you know I mean he did the same thing
in New York when a OC basically extorted
him and so or she attempted doing sort
of I basically decided not to house this
you know and what's on to headquarters
in her district and so there's this
really there's this really funny image
so we have a Seattle has a socialist
city council member named Shama Swan and
there's this video I thought what her
name is Shama Sawant South Indian she's
Indian American I thought I said samus
one like the last name was one like she
is the one she's the one sure you will
see her oftentimes on now sure like
cable news shows screaming loudly so
Shama so want there's this great video
of her she's the real proponent of this
head tax and Amazon she wants Amazon out
of the city so she honestly couldn't
give a [ __ ] if Amazon takes her if Jeff
Bezos decides like we're leaving Seattle
she wants a massage she doesn't care she
wants him out she wants like she wants a
socialist a social Reformation so
there's great video of her standing in
front of what's called Bezos balls which
with these two big glass glass
structures that he built in the middle
to Seattle and so she's standing there
and she's screaming like you know like
workers rights or what I can remember
the slogan is but something about like
an Amazon had Tax Board like to provide
you know they were gonna use the money
to deal with the homelessness crisis so
something about like helping the poor
helping the working class and then
behind her there's a couple dozen dudes
in like construction uniforms like hard
hats and they're like high visibility
vest chanting no Amazon head tags so you
have you so the problem is that the
Socialists especially this particular
socialists proclaimed sustain for the
working class while the working class
itself is basically like [ __ ] you
and that's part of identity politics
right and I think one of the problems
we're seeing now is as you mentioned
there's been this divorce it everybody's
focused on their sort of a on their
racial group their their sex their
gender their whatever they identify as
and there's much less cohesion among the
working class whereas if you wanted to
have an actual movement to raise the
minimum wage or to improve can
for workers or address income inequality
it would be I think much more effective
to have a to coalesce among the working
class and it would to splinter into
these separate groups based on this
color of our skin which i think is what
Bernie Sanders was trying to do I wasn't
a Sanders supporter because I thought he
was gonna get just trumped by Donald
Trump but I think that was his I think
had the best chance against Trump
because Sanders to me I thought Sanders
said a lot of good things about unions
and workers and the rights of people you
know to have health care and to have you
know early childhood education and like
a lot of things that would have been
positive overall for our society if he
could get them done so I really flipped
back and forth on this I thought Sanders
for a while because of the momentum that
he had after 2018 and all of this
popular support particularly mom bring
out the youth vote but he just didn't
you know his he got fewer votes and in
this primary that he did you know and in
2012 the amazing thing is that the
Sanders like groundswell support which
wasn't there
well I think part of that is because of
Elizabeth Warren because she split the
vote right yeah Warren I had been a big
Warren fan and she just turned she
turned away from being like the champion
of the consumer and the little man and
the person talking about corruption and
Paulette and you know in government
which is what you're talking about
talking about like you know like the the
quote-unquote epidemic of murder of
trans women which doesn't exist and just
this hyper focus on identity the trans
women epidemic of murder doesn't exist
Cady Herzog autism reason people are
trans go into this because you said this
to me the other day no you're not you're
gonna get [ __ ] famous can you change
your background to Charlottesville I'm
kidding Katie tell us about a lesbian
apartment this is the most Seattle
apartment everything's gray
well good for you good for you coming
away come and do it in LA and really
impress me I mean I I moved to the
suburbs so I could get away from all
this [ __ ] yeah I'm a suburban home owner
cuz all we hear is the trans women are
being murdered and nobody wants that and
we hear it we hear it and we hear trans
women of color being murdered you say no
what say you I mean okay so what'd you
hear about is the quote-unquote epidemic
of trans violence or epidemic of trans
murder so if you look at the statistics
and this the Cystic I'm about to tell
you comes from the Human Rights Campaign
so this is like the primary gay and
trans rights group in the United States
and up until recently they were
considered far too regressive on trans
issues but they have since shifted from
being a gay rights script I think
primarily a trans rights or trans
advocacy group so this is from HRC HRC
says that in 2019 25 trans people were
murdered right so 25 of anything like
just on it on its face it's just
incredible to me that people continue to
call this an epidemic because 25 of
anything isn't an epidemic right so I
ran the numbers and I I can't remember
them off the top of my head but it turns
out that when you look at look at murder
rates and this is a little bit difficult
to do because we don't really know the
population of trans people in the United
States is probably underestimated but so
using like the most current data what I
found and what other people have found
as well is that the murder rate for
trans women or trans people is slightly
lower than that for natal females and
vastly lower than the not for natal
males and it it is true that trans out
black trans women are much more likely
to be the victims of murder than like a
you know a a white trans dude in Seattle
just vastly more likely but when you
drill into the actual cases these
particular cases what you find is that
the vast majority of these people who
were killed in 2019 and 2018 and 2017
and every other year were not killed in
bias crimes they were killed doing sex
work
they were killed and it's like in
through domestic violence random bad
luck there are a couple bias crimes last
year and it's all terrible people
shouldn't be killed like let's just like
acknowledge that but this isn't an
epidemic it's actually not even
disproportionately high
it is it is hired for sure for black
trans women particularly black trans
women who are sex workers but
transphobia doesn't appear to be the
actual root of these killings and to me
if you care about trans lives and you
want trans people to be have healthy
happy lives where they are not
victimized you need to get at the root
of the issue and if the route isn't
transphobia then you need to stop
repeating this this slogan you know that
transcript Roby is killing people or
whatever because it's just not true
and so the other statistic that gets
floated around all the time all the time
this is like has been like back in the
news this week is the argument that
they're more likely to end up in sex
work because their tans and they're
discriminated against at other jobs well
I think that's probably part of the
argument you know in there are certainly
socio-economic for like factors at play
here if you're black you're more likely
to be poor if you're poor you're more
likely to be doing sex work there are
this is like real intersectionality you
know there are these like interlocking
interlocking you know characteristics
dependent on these populations but so
this other Cystic it's even crazier and
that's that's that the the life
expectancy of trans women is 35 and
sometimes they say like no it's the life
expectancy of like black trans women or
transfer of the color but you see this
repeated all the time trans women on
average only lived to be 35 years old so
I looked into this last year and that
number comes throughout from basic like
almost nowhere so there is a human
rights organization based in South
America and they pulled different like
LGBTQ advocacy groups and they asked
them they asked them they basically got
data on on like on rates of
victimization and what they found that
in like very specific populations like
sex workers and Brazilian favelas or
however you pronounce that word
so the average age of a murder victim of
a trans murder victim actually not even
average so it and this particular
population so 80% of trans murder
victims in this population were under
the age of 35 which is not actually
uncommon I mean most people who are
murdered are young but this has nothing
to do with the United States this is
extrapolated from the most some of them
dangerous areas in the world doing the
most dangerous job in the world
so has nothing to do with your average
trans person in the United States and
also a lot of trans people don't come
out until they're well after after the
age of 35 years old right so it's just
on its face it just doesn't make any
sense
but people continue to repeat it and I
think this is really bad because it
harms trans people right I mean what do
you think it would be like to like wake
up every day and think like I'm never
gonna live to be to see my 36th birthday
I'll never be able to be president
because trans women only live to be 35
years old it's just not true and it just
gets repeated and that's what drives me
crazy about the media so what happens
it's like a study will get published or
some advocacy group will commission a
study and then they'll issue a press
release and then the media picks it up
and doesn't do any sort of digging into
it doesn't look at the numbers doesn't
ask for the data it just assumes that
it's true and just starts repeating it
and then you know celebrities pick it up
and start repeating it and then it just
passes like a virus through culture and
all of a sudden people think that you
know trans women are being hunted in the
streets this came up Kamala Harris at
the LGBT town hall someone interrupted
her and said like we're being lit we're
being hunted and she said I know you are
and it's just not true there's like
there's not a serial killer going around
terrorizing trans women what's happening
is that they're being trans they're
being terrorized by misinformation that
typically well-meaning people continue
to spread because they're just not
skeptical so in closing because you
you're so smart and you people should
follow you and read everything you do
you're one of the best followers on
Twitter Kitty purr Zog on Twitter you
are somebody that I think has you know
you've ruffled a lot of feathers and and
I do we get back to facts ever in this
country do we get back to objective
information or is anybody gonna be able
to say what you just said without you
know your intentions being challenged
and being called a Nazi in a racist and
[ __ ] Herzog you know spray-painted on
the outside of the stranger is anybody
ever gonna be able to have these
conversations ever again yeah do we see
any is anything positive culturally
happening right now that might lead us
back to a more fact-based rational
discourse in this country no there it is
Rio Grande by the way agreed I agree
with you okay here's what I think is
gonna happen I think that we're in the
midst of a mass hysteria and it's not
just what's happening in trials but many
of those women were witches in there and
it's it was oddly enough being a which
is also very trendy right now so I think
we're in the midst of these things
happen in American culture or not a not
just American culture they happen all
across all across the world you see
things like the Cultural Revolution and
communist Nations and the difference
between with lots of the same sort of
social social strictures right so in
like Romania in the 70s and 80s 67 News
80s they would have these uh what were
essentially like struggle sessions he's
like mandatory self-criticism sessions
where people would get together and
publicly proclaim how they had been
enemies of the working class and usually
what they had done was some sort of
thought crime and we're seeing this now
but instead of it being sort of a
top-down directive from the government
this is coming from the bottom up right
so this is coming from the culture where
people particularly like you know a sort
of elite middle class or upper middle
class highly educated white people are
voluntarily sort of taking place in
these struggle sessions because of like
real sense of guilt and a real sense
it's like prashant profound shame about
what people with our skin tone did
before we were alive in many cases so I
think that's where this is going I hope
that I'm wrong and I think it's gonna
last for years I think that we're gonna
we're seeing something break open now
that is going to spread farther and
wider throughout society and people are
gonna get scared or and scared to speak
their minds and to be honest and I'm
deeply concerned about it I don't think
this is how like the end of the world I
think that it was wrong to Trump and now
we're gonna swing back the other way now
I keep wondering like it would be very
interesting to me you know there's all
this panic about Trump sort of issue
issuing authoritarianism into the United
States he has absolutely not been able
to do as much as he would like to and I
keep thinking like what if we do what if
he does issue authoritarianism and but
it's not the federal government it's
from the resistance right it would be
sort of like perfectly ironic could be
dude evolved into this authoritarian
society where nobody can say what they
believe and I'm not talking about you
know like I think that norms should
exist in society I don't think that we
should have no rules and people should
just go around you know
screaming racist [ __ ] or whatever I
don't think that the problem is that
what is acceptable thought what is
acceptable to express has become
increasingly narrow right so I'm talking
about just like talking about the
realities of biological sex these things
that are basic mainstream opinions
that's what I'm worried about being
today where somebody said Trump just
enshrined biological sex is defined to
men and women in the law all trans
health care is now wiped out this is
what you see on Twitter and people are
saying that's why what JK Rowling said
was so detrimental and dangerous is any
of that true I haven't looked into this
I saw I saw this floating around Twitter
I think what they did was just from like
reading a headline and really not
reading into it at all I think what they
did is roll back protections under the
obamacare under the Affordable Care Act
for trans people which I'm against you
know I think that that I think that you
know insurance companies should cover
should cover
do you know trans health care I think
that's probably what it's about you know
their argument is that JK Rowling's
expression that men and women this is
the reason yeah dude this has been in
the works for a long time and I highly
doubt that Trump is is dictating public
policy based on JK Rowling I don't know
but they're saying that's the problem
with you know biological essentialists
is that there would still funny
biological essentialist I mean even to
just say that word but you know when you
have that those types of opinions though
they allow governments to take away
health care from trans people I just I
think that's on its face I don't think
that yeah I think like two issues that
are unconnected
yeah JK Rowling she wrote a piece called
like turf wars or something and it's
sort of an explainer about why he came
out recently and sort of dipped her toe
and the conversation about about
transept and she's referring to
something really specific that's
happening in the UK this gender
recognition act
which would move from a process there's
basically because of the NHS the
National Health Service there if you
want sort of trans health care you have
to basically go in front of a panel I
think I'm getting this right you
basically have to go through there's
steps that you have to go through to get
health care there's sort of more of a
gatekeeper method there and then in like
20 18 or something
ironically the Conservative Party
introduced this gender recognition act
and the reason they did this was because
this was on the heels of gay marriage
and gay marriage with such an
overwhelming popular success I thought
like hey well just like well like jump
on this bandwagon and do something for
the trans people and everybody's gonna
love us and so what they proposed with
this law that would make a sex change
would be basically self self declaration
right so if you say right now that
you're a woman legally you are female
and you have access to women's spaces if
I say I'm a man I have access to men
spaces and so the Conservative Party
proposed this and then there was a
massive backlash not just between like
radical feminists who don't want trans
women in their spaces but like Catholic
women and mainstream normies just women
who said like we are uncomfortable with
this so she's talking about something
really specific and not trans out here
and I think she liked it affirmed her
you know her belief that trans people
should have access to health care right
one one last question you said you you
got into writing about D transition
because you're interested in heretics
and now you've kind of become a heretic
yeah I think you manifested that is that
did you want to always kind of live on
the outside of mainstream so I mean I
kind of do which is why I'm a comedian
right like my job I guess other than
prostitution is like the second oldest
job like I'm like the town crier I'm the
fool I'm the whatever like I'm the guy
that's in the public square just
shouting and then people come by and
throw them change whatever but what
about heretics so fascinated you and and
you seem very comfortable being one I
guess that's probably because I haven't
left my house in three months and so I'm
like I no longer have people screaming
at me yeah I mean an element of
self-reflection there I don't think it
was conscious at the time but I would
say that the writing that I've done
before and you know and after that piece
tends to I I try to find the unexpected
and
things you know and I've learned that
almost nothing nothing you see is as it
appears to be and so I think that's a
part why I'm drawn to these things and
then the more I read the more I realize
that everything I think I know about the
world is uh is more complex than I
thought so yes more and more informed
you get the less you know you feel like
you have any clue of what's going on and
the less you realize you can trust
institutions and I don't want to be like
you know I'm not Donald Trump I don't
unfortunately I don't have his his money
or his tan spray tan but you know I
don't believe in like the I don't want
to be like the fake news person or
whatever but I will say like a lot of
mainstream and I saw the current media
it's the carving team thing happened was
completely fake jussie Smollett I mean
there's a lot we've seen a lot okay I
got a question for you yeah yeah how how
long did it take for you to think like
Jesse smelly does [ __ ] well you know
what bothered me about the Jesse
smollett saying and this is what always
bothers me and and I I've I spent my
life in New York City LA I've been a
Chicago Bunch
I have witnessed very few things that I
would consider you know and I've been in
places where everybody's drunk I spent a
lot of time with drunks in comedy clubs
I think like that people have yelled
things out at me I mean it's part of the
[ __ ] contract you signed up for when
you're a comedian I've been on subways
late at night and all that stuff the
idea that there were these Trump
supporting gang of people in a
metropolitan city committing hate crime
seemed very weird to me impossible no
but it seemed odd to me that that
whenever when I heard that it made me go
huh really and 2:00 a.m. there's just
guys with Trump hats on going after
Jesse smollett who's getting a Subway
sandwich at 2:00 a.m. yeah that was the
thing that got me I was like aren't you
rich why are you eating subway why
aren't you making moose mating or
GrubHub and something Wireless freezing
you and
I and I and I did a video about this
several weeks later I was always
attacked by Elizabeth Warren supporters
I was hit with feathers in a headdress
and I was attacked and so I understand
what it's like but did you do you did
they come back and apologize to you
after collision I'm sure that they did
what weird thinking about me is this
again I came out late in life I came out
of 25 then I started stand-up comedy
right away I quit drinking the same year
so you had all of these things happenin
once I became essentially another person
right I never had the time to like just
be gay for two years and like just party
and drug it up and [ __ ] I came out I had
to stop doing drugs and drinking and I
started doing comedy so it was this
weird Prabhas and actors little kid like
I have a lot of traditionally gay
experiences right I'm insanely talented
and gorgeous so when you have I do I and
you know what I look like how they do
when they don't do as well because they
see an older ballerinas so the reality
is you're wrong and right at the same
time but I always you know here's the
thing man I hate groupthink
I've always hated it's so weird to me
it's the antithesis of humor like this
there's this weird kind of cultish I you
know I was a drug addict I understand
what it's like to live this binary
existence of like I'm either high or I'm
sober I'm getting drugs I'm not getting
drugs and so to me when I got rid of
drugs and I stopped drinking and I went
into comedy and I was doing this and I
was following the path that I should be
following like I just I I really started
to get weird about people that had you
know no room for nuance because I'm like
that's where everything lives everything
lives in nuanced jokes live in nua and
i've always a fan of like you know you
know people people say i don't present
as gay so it's easier for me 100% true
they're 100% right about that but like
being gay is the tenth most [ __ ] up
thing about me right in terms of the
life I've lived I mean I bought a house
when I was 22 with the subprime mortgage
on cocaine I mean you know most people
wake up you know gate
we'll wake up or straight people wake up
next to someone and go how did I get
here
I woke up as $700,000 home and said how
did I get here and then it was yeah and
I owned the property so I had done all
this weird [ __ ] I mean I dropped acid on
8th grade stage of my graduation oh you
know I was doing acid when I was in
eighth grade I was doing cocaine in
eighth grade in ninth grade I was
hanging out at crack houses I was like
doing wild stuff and then I was selling
subprime mortgages for a long time
trying to help the country really and
and and I was just involved in all this
weird [ __ ] man and to me sexuality is a
part of the story but it's not the whole
story for most people it is their whole
story most gay people for most people it
is there's something wrong with that
because it's like you're completely
right yeah I find it like very I find it
aggravating and I don't find it I don't
find it interesting at all but you know
and like I lived like mostly in Queens
sort of queer circles for most of my
life until I basically got
excommunicated in the last few years and
when I think back about that time it's
like all we talked about was being gay
that's all we talked about right
somebody be like paper or plastic and
I'd be like I'm gay everywhere is
everyone everyone's gay now and it's
weird it's so I always felt like yeah
I'm sure I had internalized homophobia
this and the other thing but then like
there was a time of comedy when I
started to a comedy when I said I was
gay on stage people say ooh or like
people would be like openly hostile to
it but then it turned to where like I
even like it when in longer sets I say
it in short sets I stop saying it
because when I said it people would clap
and that's the worst thing in comedy few
big good for you good for you and then
alejo enough what a weird [ __ ] thing
what but people are heavily invested in
that which makes them unique and if what
makes you unique is your sexuality and
otherwise you're a basic [ __ ] person if
what makes you unique is you sick which
is what I love about all these people
they're like I'm queer
and I love the Real Housewives and I
love you know frappuccino and I'm like
you're just a basic [ __ ] right it
doesn't matter who you sleep with you
like you you have nothing unique about
you groups of queers are conformist like
every other group they are I mean we
break up into these tribes it's not that
different from high school and they're
all like each other and you know I'm
that's I guess an offensive thing to say
but it's cuz like Long's observations
with hanging out with these communities
yeah I mean how does it affect you like
are you when you say you're actually
muna Kate do you just not get the
invites anymore what no yeah I don't
I've like basically live a pretty
friendless existence and I do have I
have like three or four friends I mean
most of them are older okay I have
friends in like their 60s and 70s now I
just don't like just some old Mountain
lesbian you talk to a houseboat and she
chain smokes inside is what you want
that you don't want a lot of friends you
chain smoker in the [ __ ] 70s to learn
how to be a pilot I mean she's just
fascinating or I could hang out with
career people who only talked about
being queer right so yeah I would say I
don't have very many friends but I do
have a wife and a dog so I'm so okay you
know it's like when you when you look at
the 60s Camille Paglia talks about this
when you look at like what the because
there was a lot of similar ideas
happening but it was all about sensory
experiences in LSD in the body and
people [ __ ] and free love and
Hinduism and like you know expanding
your mind and then you look at this
revolution and it's all about like
nitpicking language and like a very
journalists secretarial you know weird
bureaucratic sexless fearful existence
and you're like whoa they got everything
raw they took like everything from the
60s and now it's like I get the bad [ __ ]
they took all the bad [ __ ] notes people
just chewing their tongues on adderall
going on tweet threads it's like crazy
and what's scary is what's next that's
what's always scared me I'm like is
violence next because it seems like
everywhere in the culture from
celebrities to the media there is just a
it's violence is being excused and even
like in certain corners of the media
agitated and like requested right it's
justified because it's violence in the
name of a righteous cause you know it's
it's I don't think people have are very
aware of like recent history around the
world its but it's really good a this is
new yeah it's good because we can see
how we can see sort of these patterns
you know he would these mass panics
assist areas they come and they go and I
think I think where anyone and you can't
really see it until until it's over tell
people were to find you where can they
support you where can they read your
stuff so my podcast is sort of my main
thing now I decided I don't want to be a
writer anymore words are over or writing
is over I'm just going to be a speaker
now so my podcast is called blocked and
reported and we're on patreon
it's like blocked and reported at
patreon I don't know what it is you can
google it I'm on Twitter at Kitty purr
Zog and that's I guess that's the only
places I want you to find me that's
where she wants to be found she's a
one-woman wrecking crew doing battle
against autistic trans communists and if
there's if there's if you don't see the
value in that well I don't know what to
tell you thank you for doing the show I
appreciate it you are you're not a
retweet her she never retweets what I do
but I enjoy her anyway she doesn't read
to I keeps big tabs on that she never
retweets but that's okay but she's she's
a follow on Twitter man if you're not
following kitty pers on on Twitter she's
a great follow I love the way her mind
works it's very very fascinating and
good luck man listen patreon and all of
these things are the future like these
one of the things that I'll kind of
close with this what bothers me about
people in my industry is that they're
they're supposedly super progressive but
they're all married to these archaic
institutions they're like let's reform
Hollywood is it what are you saying
create your own avenues you have the
technology to do your own thing I've
made a hundred sketches in the past two
years
they're funny they get millions of views
they've never been on television they
have we put them on Twitter and
Instagram and YouTube we they're you
know we put out two podcasts a week you
know nobody inhibits us from doing this
there's no
nobody's telling us what to say or what
to do when we live and die on on
basically the response of the audience
and yet so many of the most progressive
most evolved minds of my business still
refuse to do that because they don't
really want to put their talent in the
hands of the audience they want to
basically they like these cartels as
much as they don't want to admit that
they love these cartels of people that
will either greenlight something they
want to do or not so it'll be in what
you're doing right now what I'm doing I
mean this is just kind of it this is
kind of it
yeah and it's actually working out it's
shocking yeah it's shocking well listen
good luck with everything thank you you
welcome back any time I appreciate it I
know it was an honor for you today to
speak to me I was I appreciate it thank
you very much